how's it going everybody it's Warren and
there's a lot of talk right now about
who this mysterious new villain is
that's going to pop up in Avengers 4 so
not too long ago we got the leaked toy
that had Thor and rocket on it and on
the back of the toy box there was a
description that said a new threat was
coming a lot of people thought that this
might not necessarily mean that a new
villain is coming but merely a different
threat from Thanos is coming however in
the book the cosmic quest vol 2
aftermath we learned that it is in fact
a new foe the book mentions Thanos and
it mentions the snap but separately the
very last line of the back of the book
reads little do they know that a new foe
who threatens to destroy them all is
looming so it's a separate different foe
than Thanos than the snap and
everybody's wondering just who this
could be
well there's a popular opinion going
around right now before infinity war
came out I did a video on how I thought
that lady death would be in the movie
somehow and be behind Thanos but she was
nowhere to be found in the movie and
they actually rewrote Thanos as origin
in the MCU
however after infinity war the Russo
brothers came out and said that in
Avengers 4 we can expect to see comic
book characters that have never appeared
in the MCU so after this I did another
video stating that lady death could be
in Avengers 4 and now there's a lot of
videos going around right now about how
she could be this new foe in Avengers 4
and I think she very well could be
because if you think back to what the
Russo brothers said before infinity war
came out they said that infinity War
part 1 and part 2 at the time as it was
being called was all about Thanos
it was Thanos movie it was being told
from the perspective of Thanos and they
even deleted a bunch of scenes with the
black order with fan oohs as a child
there was a lot that they didn't put in
there but from the start this movie has
been about Thanos and the Russo brothers
himself said that they draw inspiration
from the comics well Lady Death is a
huge part of Thanos a story in the
comics and there are ways that she could
enter Avengers for something really
caught my attention a few weeks ago when
a fan asked the Russo brothers a
question
in a QA that they did with Collider the
fans stated that in guardians of the
galaxy Gamora says that she is the last
of her species but an infinity war
Thanos tells Gamora that her planet is
thriving and that there are little kids
on the planet and they are not hungry
anymore
so these are two completely opposite
things going on here and when the fan
asked which one was real the only thing
the rooster brothers replied was who do
you believe fan O's or Gamora
so naturally I think everyone would
probably believe Gamora / Thanos so this
got me thinking what if Thanos is lying
about why he's balancing the universe
I'm not saying that his origin is fake
and that all the people on Titan did not
die I'm just saying what if there's a
little bit more to it in the comics he
performs the snap for Lady Death he does
it to impress her
in the comics everything fan OHS mostly
does is for Lady Death Lady Death is sad
that there are more people alive than
there are dead so fan OHS sets out to
get the Infinity stones so he can
perform the snap and balance the
universe for Lady Death fan OHS lives to
serve Lady Death it would not surprise
me if she ended up on the farm with fan
OHS in Avengers 4 and then when the
Avengers tried to undo fan oh snap she
obviously has a big problem with this so
she could very well become a villain in
Avengers 4 a lot of people thought that
hella could maybe become Lady Death but
seeing as how she died at the end of
thor ragnarok that's not very likely but
there is a new theory going around right
now that maybe Lady Death as Helles
mother and this theory comes from reddit
user Reinhardt one two three if you
think about it this actually makes a lot
of sense because in Avengers infinity
war when Thor is telling his story to
Gamora he says that he had a half-sister
which means that hella does not have the
same mother that Thor has and hella is
the goddess of death who do you think
her mother is so this could also be a
way that lady death comes into the
picture in Avengers 4 she finds out that
her daughter died now of course as death
herself she could revive hella but she'd
still be pretty ticked off and she could
of course still be connected to Thanos
romantically so as you can see there are
many different ways that it would make
total sense to have lady death in
Avengers 4 so let me know your
lots of my theory on Reinhart 1 2 3 s
theory and let me know if you have any
theories about how lady death could be
the new villain and Avengers 4 if you
have them yourself let me know in the
comments below and I'm giving away a
life-size Infinity Gauntlet if you would
like to enter for your chance to win all
you have to do is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero as always thank you
all so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you